what do you think about the meeting
between Harmony and Vladimir Putin in
July
what's that Alliance what's that
partnership
is its surface level geopolitics is
there a deep growing connection
I cannot see the difference between
geopolitics and these deep connections I
see this one and the same why
because I think the experience
of 40 Years of
distancing from the West
in terms of the Islamic Republic
and the fact that there is a
shelf life to Imperial presence yeah for
any Empire anywhere in the world
so after the terrible experience of of
the United States in
Iraq
and in Afghanistan
pretty pretty much like the British
Empire that after destroys the
experience in 56
decided to withdraw from
uh east of Suez
maybe there is a moment here that we are
witnessing or it may come
that a great power like the United
States sees in its benefits not to get
too much involved into nitty-gritty
things in other parts of the world that
it's not its immediate cancer
and I think that's
is part of the reason not the entire
reason part of the reason why we see the
emergence of a new
geopolitical
environments in this part of the world
of which China
Russia
possibly Iran possibly turkey possibly
both of them are going to be part
perhaps Saudis also but I doubt that the
Saudis under the present circumstances
although we witnessed some remarkable
issue in the course of the past few
weeks where the Saudis giving assurances
to American Administration and then
shifting and getting along with Putin
in terms of the oil production I think
is more than that event and it's not
only them but also the Emirates are
doing the same thing so what does that
this tell us and that's another
many our conversation about the the
world industry in in Iran and the the
whole region in emerging this kind of a
world
which was perhaps even 10 years ago
unimaginable yeah that you see now a
great power China that it's going to
remain from what we see around us as a
great power
and Russia adventurous
foolish but nevertheless would remain
a criminal I would say as far as the Its
Behavior in Ukraine
but actually it's a rogue nation that it
attracts another Rogue Nation so Iran
finds itself now in a greater place of
security in Alliance with Russia in the
hope that this would give Iran a
greatest Security in this part of the
world
whether this is whether this is a
realistic or a illusion
I think remains to be seen I think Iran
China relation makes more sense
uh although if you ask ordinary Iranians
they don't like it
they will tell why should we be tied up
with uh with China as the only uh trade
party with with America because of the
foolish isolations that you have created
for us because of all the sanctions that
you have created for us the Islamic
Republic
so in a sense it's a very difficult
question to answer probably Iranians
also like to be more on the other camp
but what happens is that in real term
so what surprises me most
is not this alliance with China but it's
kind of becoming
a lucky or subservient
to Putin's regime in in Russia
since if you look at it
Iran
ever since at least the 19th century not
going further back
the beginning of the 19th century always
viewed Russia as the greatest threat
strategically because it was sitting
right at the top of Iran it was
uh it was
infinitely more powerful than Iran has
ever been
and he runs for two rounds of War at the
beginning of the century lost the entire
caucuses
to Russia and led its lesson
that
you have to be mindful of Russia
and you have to keep it as an arms
length and that's what was the Iran's
policies throughout the course of the
20th century 19th and 20th Century up to
what we see now around us which is a
very strange situation
um
whether the balance has changed
in terms of
if this if Russia is purchasing weapons
from
from Iran which was unheard of
it means that there is a new
balance is emerging a new relationship
is emerging
perhaps remains to be seen but uh
if you look at the Historical precedence
it would have been enormously unwise
to be an ally of Russia given its long
history of aggression in Iran see
Russians
part of the reason why it's actually
Iran Allied itself with British Empire
was the fact that it was so much afraid
of the Russian expansion
and as such I don't know what's going to
be the future of this relationship there
is a big disconnect between governments
and the people and I think ultimately I
have faith that there's a love across
the different cultures across the
different religions amongst the people
and the governments are the source of
the division and the conflict and the
wars and all the geopolitics that isn't
part grounded in the battle for
resources and all that kind of stuff
nevertheless this is the world we live
in